Oui Oui
[musique]
ah ah
Oui Oui
Du monde de la connaissance, Translate se retire
Sortez et envoyez-moi un texto, je vois aussi le nom de l'auteur
Le produit est là pour comprendre Oncle Xuan Lan
Le moment est-il venu de ce côté-ci ?
Le groupe d'histoire va éjaculer que c'est juste
Est-ce un peu cheap d'être chanteur ?
Oui Oui
[musique]
OUI
J'ai un temps le matin mais c'est cher
obtenir les droits habituels de Mao pour moi
il n'y a rien qui nécessite un réseau pour partir
A quoi sert la terre ?
Le chant est la règle des heures supplémentaires
pourquoi est-ce si difficile, ça va
quoi manger, ta famille est si belle
les jeans regardent toujours l'équipe d'Asie du Sud
Oui Oui